I know the Republicans have some unease  about it no matter what they say because  if the president can declare an  emergency on it something that he has  created as an emergency and an illusion  that he wants to convey just think of  what a president with different values  can present to the American people you  want to talk about a national emergency  let's talk about today the one-year  anniversary of another manifestation of  the epidemic of gun violence in America  that's a national emergency  why don't you declare that emergency mr.  president I wish you would but a  Democratic president can do that  Democratic president can declare  emergencies as well so the precedent  that the president is setting here  something that should be met with great  unease and dismay by the Republicans and  of course we will respond accordingly  when we review our options first we have  to see what the president actually says